it's the only piece that moves
differently at different points of the
game on its starting Square the pawn can
move both one but also two squares
forward if it wants anywhere but the
starting Square the pawn can only move
one square at a time to capture the pawn
moves diagonally instead of
straightforward only one square at a
time and no you cannot capture two
squares diagonally from the starting row
let's take this position
this Pawn has three possible moves it
could move here
it could also move here
or it could actually capture here of
course the best move is the one that
captures the bishop since the pawn has
now moved it can never move two squares
forward on one turn again there's one
last trick to pawns if you can get your
Pawn all the way to the other side of
the board you can actually promote it to
a queen Rook bishop or a knight pawns
May begin as lowly pieces but they have
their power in numbers and great
potential to promote